y
[Música]
en una sesión que todavía está en curso
en el senado chileno la oposición no
consiguió los votos necesarios para
destituir al presidente sebastián piñera
se necesitaba un mínimo de 29 apoyos
para que el mandatario tuviera que dejar
el cargo tras una acusación
constitucional impulsada por sus
detractores tras su implicación en los
papeles de pandora ampliamos desde
santiago
el gobierno de eeuu de todo la entrada
al país del presidente nicaragüense
daniel ortega y los demás integrantes
del ejecutivo
washington los acusó de beneficiarse
implementando políticas y acciones que
dañan las instituciones democráticas en
nicaragua también de represión a la
oposición y autoritarismo tenemos
reporte
por considerar que atenta contra los
derechos humanos la organización mundial
de la salud pidió a los gobiernos a ser
cautelosos al momento de exigir la
vacunación obligatoria y el porte de un
certificado de vacunación como
estrategia para combatir la pandemia el
anuncio revivió el debate sobre la
libertad de los ciudadanos y la
necesidad de combatir el kobe 19
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos esta
emisión de noticias en chile donde el
senado continúa la discusión de la
acusación constitucional contra el
presidente sebastián piñera sin embargo
la oposición no logró los votos
necesarios lo que significa que el
mandatario no será destituido desde
santiago nuestra corresponsal patricia
luna nos amplió esta información
la acusación constitucional contra el
presidente de chile sebastián piñera fue
rechazada puesto que más de un tercio de
los senadores ya votaron en contra y de
esta forma la oposición que necesitaba
29 votos y sólo tenía 24 no consiguió
los cinco votos adicionales para
concretar esta acusación constitucional
que eventualmente hubiera supuesto la
destitución del presidente la acusación
se produce por el escándalo de los
papeles de pandora en los que se acusa a
la familia de sebastián piñera de vender
a uno de los mejores amigos de sebastián
piñera un proyecto empresarial cuyo
último pago estaba vinculado al hecho de
que la zona donde se iba a instalar este
proyecto minero no fuera declarada zona
de protección ambiental algo que es
potestad exclusivamente del presidente
el presidente sebastián piñera enfrenta
una investigación de la fiscalía por
presuntos delitos tributarios de cohecho
y soborno y también esta acusación
constitucional que fue rechazada por los
senadores oficialistas argumentando que
no se habían presentado pruebas y
también que se trataba de una argucia
política por parte de la oposición que
trata de sacar rédito político dicen a
esta acusación que se presenta tan solo
cinco días antes de las elecciones
presidenciales unas de las elecciones
presidenciales más inciertas que se han
vivido en chile en los últimos años
hablamos ahora de eeuu que vetó el
ingreso a su país del presidente
nicaragüense daniel ortega y de los
demás integrantes de su administración
la casa blanca emitió un comunicado en
el que acusa al ejecutivo de represión
contra opositores autoritarismo e
impulsar políticas antidemocráticas que
invalidaron el proceso electoral
desarrollado el pasado 7 de noviembre el
que ortega fue reelegido desde san jose
en costa rica a nuestra corresponsal
cindy regidor nos dio más detalles
al menos 40 países desconocen la
reelección del presidente daniel ortega
y las reacciones internacionales no
paran esta semana nuevas sanciones
fueron impuestas a funcionarios de su
gobierno por parte de eeuu canadá y el
reino unido- que se suman a rondas
anteriores de sanciones económicas
inclusive dirigidas hacia la
vicepresidenta y primera dama rosario
murillo a los hijos de la pareja
presidencial altos funcionarios
gubernamentales e instituciones públicas
ya sea por actos de corrupción o por
violaciones a los derechos humanos la
organización de estados américanos la
semana pasada resolvió con el voto de 25
países que la reelección de ortega no
tiene legitimidad en respuesta a la
asamblea nacional nicaragüense
controlada también por ortega pide
desligarse de la oea un proceso que
tomaría dos años y conllevaría el
aislamiento del país a lo que aún no
reacciona ortega es a la más reciente
medida del presidente joe biden que
prohibió el ingreso a suelo
estadounidense de daniel ortega rosario
murillo y cualquier funcionario de su
gobierno incluyendo cónyuges e hijos
bardem también mantuvo la declaración
que considera que la situación de
nicaragua es una amenaza a la seguridad
de eeuu el periodista estadounidense
danny fenster regresó a su país
procedente de mianmar en donde fue
condenado a 11 años de prisión por el
gobierno militar que tomó el poder en
ese país tras un golpe de estado fenster
fue recibido por amigos familiares y
medios de comunicación a quienes comentó
no guardar resentimiento tras haber
permanecido seis meses arrestado andrés
amaya nos da los detalles en su
reportaje
un largo abrazo después de meses de
ausencia el periodista de estadounidense
danny fenster volvió a casa luego de
seis meses de incertidumbre detenido en
mianmar
todo el día no supe que estaba
regresando a casa estaba en la prisión
de yangon esta mañana y me dijeron que
empacar a una maleta con lo que
necesitara
me metieron a un automóvil esposado de
manos y pies me dijeron que no hiciera
preguntas o dijera nada
junto a él estuvo el ex gobernador de
nuevo méxico bill richardson quien ayuda
en las negociaciones con el país
asiático asegurando la liberación del
periodista con ayuda humanitaria y
vacunas contra él con 19
en la liberación de danny sucedió en dos
semanas orgullos
hubo cuatro reuniones de las directivas
del centro richardson para el compromiso
global con el comandante en jefe de la
junta de mianmar yo le dije que esto
sería un regalo un gesto humanitario al
pueblo estadounidense y fue lo correcto
danny era un periodista haciendo su
trabajo
de
fenster de 37 años trabajaba como editor
de una revista en mianmar cuando fue
detenido por las autoridades y
sentenciado a 11 años de prisión por
cargos de incitación violaciones de las
leyes de inmigración y reunión ilegal
desde nueva york dijo que seguirá
luchando por los que permanecen
detenidos entre ellos por lo menos 47
periodistas más tienen a mi familia y
amigos en mianmar todavía no he podido
comunicarme con ellos todavía hay mucho
trabajo por hacer allí según la
asociación de asistencia para
prisioneros políticos más de 10.000
personas han sido arrestadas desde el
golpe militar del primero de febrero en
miami marc además cerca de mil 260
personas han muerto a causa de la
violencia durante las manifestaciones
por parte de las fuerzas de seguridad la
organización mundial de la salud que la
vacunación obligatoria o la imposición
de un bloqueo a las personas no
vacunadas plantea problemas de derechos
humanos y llamó a los países a decidir
medidas con mucho cuidado para controlar
la pandemia
[Música]
ellos necesitan estar absolutamente
seguros de que los beneficios de hacer
eso superan los riesgos y que ellos han
hecho todo lo posible por abordar las
dudas sobre las vacunas otros problemas
y sienten que no tienen otra alternativa
si este tipo de mandatos son ejecutados
necesitan implementarse por el menor
tiempo posible y como lo he dicho
necesitan ser coherentes con la salud
pública y los derechos humanos
and white el laboratorio pzifer anunció
la firma de un acuerdo global que
permitirá la fabricación genérica de su
píldora experimental contra el hobbit
1995 países con ingresos medios y bajos
pzifer que comercializa una de las
vacunas anti cobit más usadas del mundo
sostiene que su píldora reduce en un 89
por ciento el riesgo de hospitalización
y muerte en pacientes con sintomatología
moderada
el fármaco se usará en combinación con
el ritonavir un antiviral contra el vih
los fabricantes genéricos podrán lanzar
sus propias versiones de la píldora cuyo
tratamiento se espera incluya a un 53%
de la población mundial
en francia las autoridades desmantelaron
uno de los mayores campamentos de
migrantes situado en el norte del país
el ministro del interior regional de
manu anunció la destrucción del
asentamiento ubicado frente a las costas
del canal de la mancha desde donde miles
de migrantes parten hacia las islas
británicas una travesía que ha generado
fuertes tensiones entre londres y parís
desalojados por la fuerza el gobierno
francés ordenó el desmantelamiento de un
gran campamento de migrantes en el norte
de la capital parís unas mil personas
procedentes de irak siria y pakistán
estaban acampadas en precarias
condiciones
esta mañana ha llegado la policía han
cortado las tiendas las han quemado y
han metido a la gente en el autobús para
llevarlos no sé a donde
el improvisado campamento era un punto
de partida de los migrantes hacia el
reino unido a través del canal de la
mancha lo hacen en embarcaciones
inseguras la semana pasada más de 1000
personas lograron cruzar a territorio
británico aumentando las tensiones entre
londres y parís
para resolver el problema de las redes
de paso de los campamentos informales de
insalubres y de las muertes durante la
travesía lo que se necesita son días
legales de paso a reino unido no
expulsiones de esta magnitud que sólo
hacen que la gente pierda las pocas
pertenencias que les quedan las
autoridades francesas estarían
ofreciendo a los migrantes la
posibilidad de presentar sus solicitudes
de asilo en su territorio y refugio pero
muchos quieren continuar su camino a
reino unido la ong utopía 56 denuncia
que los migrantes fueron obligados a
subirse a los autobuses estatales sin
conocer su destino
esta es principalmente la política de
acoso e intimidación que es parte de una
política global de no asilo asegurando
que la gente no quiera quedarse y no
haga que otros vengan en el último año
las travesías de migrantes de refugiados
a través del canal superan los 23 mil
casos una cifra récord
un grupo de diputados franceses solicitó
que su país le conceda asilo político al
fundador de wikileaks julian assange
para evitar que responda ante la
justicia de eeuu que pide su extradición
desde gran bretaña 40 parlamentarios
firmaron una propuesta de resolución en
la que afirman que francia no puede
guardar silencio frente a lo que
consideran un ensañamiento judicial y
político
el ministro de exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov respondió este martes a las
críticas formuladas contra su país por
el ensayo con un misil que detonó un
satélite fuera de uso desde los años 80
causando basura en el espacio y poniendo
en peligro la estación espacial
internacional además de eeuu la otan se
sumó a los llamados de atención el
informe es de rafael pérez
un nuevo enfrentamiento entre potencias
espaciales y
declarar que la federación de rusia crea
riesgos al uso pacífico del espacio es
como mínimo hipócrita no hay hechos
de tajante fue la respuesta del
canciller ruso sérguei lávrov que puso
en duda las preocupaciones de eeuu por
el ensayo este lunes de un proyectil
anti satélite por parte de moscú contra
uno de sus propios aparatos espaciales
su unión wiston como eeuu pide como
ellos mismos dicen que se elaboren
normas universales para la exploración
del espacio pero por alguna razón han
ignorado durante muchos años la
iniciativa de rusia y china- de preparar
un tratado para evitar una carrera
armamentística en el espacio
yo soy seguro si el secretario general
de la otan james steinberg también
expresó su malestar sobre la prueba
balística
just news space ones cuando rusia
aprueba ahora nuevas armas espaciales
cuando lo hacen también destruyen la
capacidad espacial creando gran cantidad
de desechos peligrosos
ahora nos concierne a ambos porque los
restos son actualmente un riesgo para la
actividad civil
pero es también preocupante porque eso
demuestra que rusia está desarrollando
un nuevo sistema de armas que puede
derribar satélites
downs atlantes según el departamento de
estado estadounidense el impacto contra
el satélite ruso creó más de 1.500
piezas de basura que pusieron en peligro
la integridad de la estación espacial
internacional los siete astronautas que
conviven allí tuvieron que refugiarse en
sus respectivos cápsulas de descenso
como medida de precaución
y tres atentados suicidas sacudieron la
ciudad de kampala capital de uganda en
los hechos fallecieron seis personas
entre ellas los tres atacantes más de 30
personas resultaron heridas este tipo de
atentados no son comunes en este país
africano el autodenominado estado
islámico se adjudicó la autoría del
hecho
estas imágenes de la policía ugandesa
registrando una primera explosión frente
a una comisaría en el corazón de la
capital kampala pero unos minutos
después dos explosiones adicionales se
produjeron cerca del parlamento
my friends' colca tongo japonés que es
lamentable ver esto he perdido a uno de
mis amigos llamado katongo lee un
oficial de policía si esta gente puede
venir a estos locales de la policía
hacer estallar una bomba entonces sabes
que las cosas no van bien te dan orgullo
el martes el grupo estado islámico
reivindicó los atentados está
relacionado con el grupo local de las
fuerzas democráticas aliadas
las características del atentado indican
claramente que el grupo radicalizado
vinculado al asad de efe o fuerzas
democráticas aliadas que siguen deseando
llevar a cabo atentados mortales contra
objetivos vulnerables utilizando
atacantes suicidas y artefactos
explosivos improvisados están detrás de
estos atentados las fuerzas democráticas
aliadas fueron fundadas en la década de
1990 por rebeldes ugandeses que
denunciaban una persecución de los
musulmán aunque tienen su base en la
vecina república democrática del congo
donde se les atribuye a la muerte de
miles de civiles el mes pasado el grupo
reivindicó por primera vez una explosión
en suelo ugandés según algunos analistas
la sade efe decidieron apuntar de nuevo
a su país de origen uganda y a su
antiguo enemigo el presidente yoweri
museveni que lleva 35 años en el poder
en 2019 el grupo estado islámico comenzó
a atribuirse la autoría de los atentados
de la sade efe y en marzo washington
estableció oficialmente un vínculo entre
ambos llegamos hacia el final de esta
emisión de noticias a ustedes gracias
por su sintonía pueden ampliar toda la
información en nuestra web france24
puntocom volvemos en breve con más aquí
en france 24
[Música]